what if all the oceans disappeared from
the Earth's surface
what would a world with no high seas
look like what would happen to all the
creatures that live under water could
humanity survive on the planet if there
were no oceans left this is what if and
here's what would happen if all the
Earth's oceans evaporated in the early
years of our planet the earth was flat
but not in a way you might think the
earth just didn't have any mountains and
was mostly covered with water then about
a billion years ago
land emerged from under the sea and
changed the planet's atmosphere this led
to the debut of the first life-forms
here on earth eventually the planet will
heat up and all the oceans will vanish
this isn't scheduled to happen for
another billion years but how bad would
it be if all the oceans evaporated right
now today oceans cover about 70% of the
Earth's surface if you put all that
water into Olympic sized swimming pools
you'd need over 500 trillion of them
with all the oceans gone we'd still have
some water available oceans account for
97% of all the water on the planet
the remaining 3% is held in rivers lakes
underground water even the ice caps but
that wouldn't be enough to make up for
the loss of the oceans the world's
oceans act as a global climate control
system they absorb most of the sun's
heat and distribute it evenly around the
planet so that no one area gets too hot
or too cold they also sustain the water
cycle evaporating into clouds and then
raining back to earth but you won't need
to keep your umbrella at hand expecting
a big storm once all the oceans
evaporated in our scenario the earth
wouldn't be able to keep all that vapour
in the atmosphere oceans would leave our
planet for good turning it into a vast
scorching desert
see creatures would be the obvious first
casualties in these conditions then with
no oceans to absorb the heat from the
Sun the earth would slowly roast until
it turned into Venus how long would we
have until our planet became
uninhabitable
well whatever water was left would
evaporate in a matter of days leaving
humanity to die from dehydration most
animals would go extinct without water
who knows maybe camels would become
Earth's next civilization after a few
days plants would give up their attempts
to survive without water after a few
weeks the same would happen to our
forests eventually they'd catch fire and
would keep burning until there was no
vegetation left in about a year's time
the earth would turn into a burnt and
lifeless Rock and without water it
probably wouldn't get the chance to
produce life ever again
maybe one day another life-form might
visit our solar system and wonder what
happened to our once glorious planet but
that's a story for another what if
you